hey guys today i'm doing another video
request now some of you asked me daniel
how can i be more charismatic as a man
the oxford dictionary says charismatic
is exercising a compelling charm
which inspires devotion in others
now you guys know that at the beginning
when i started my youtube channel
i was terrible i mean my tone of voice
my fast-paced speaking my expressions
and body language terrible
i realized that i had to improve my
charisma if i wanted to be successful
with online videos not just with the
videos but
with life itself
so i learned a lot of things over the
years and i improved myself and that is
what i want to share with you today
let's get to it
[Music]
alright guys there are five things that
you need to focus on to improve your
charisma as a man speech
eye contact
non-verbal behavior facial expression
and lastly know your audience now let's
start with speech first
tone of voice
you're not going to sound charismatic or
inspire others if you speak too soft
because first of all they can't probably
hear what you're saying and two you
don't sound that confident when you
speak soft as well
then the other problem is speaking too
loud if you speak too loud
people think you're more arrogant and
selfish
you know there's these crazy bad sales
companies and they teach you you have to
speak loud to control the conversation
is the worst advice ever i know because
that's what i used to do
when i finished school i went to england
and i did sales gas and electric and
that's what they taught us is the worst
advice ever if you do this all the time
if you raise your voice to try to
control the conversation people will
think that you are arrogant and bossy
so too soft is a problem too loud is a
problem so you need a balance somewhere
in the middle if you can do that you
will sound humble and confident
pause
have you ever realized in all my videos
or let's say the recent videos i always
pause after i want to emphasize a
certain point
i just did it again just now never rush
all your words so that everything you
are saying sounds exactly the same like
what i'm doing right now then it's just
boring
pause
just give the person some time to take
in what you've just said
and then
show them your facial expressions show
them that you're not done talking yet so
they know okay there's more to come make
them curious make them want to hear more
emphasize important words
there are some people who just speak the
same words with the same content on
their voice and it's just boring to
listen to them and you just want to fall
asleep because there's no pauses between
the words i don't emphasize certain
words and you just want to fall asleep
no speak with confidence direction and
with passion you do this by letting
people feel the words that you are
saying so you emphasize certain words
for example look at this sentence hey
john i went fishing the other day for
big tunas to eat delicious sashimi now
let's say it again by emphasizing the
most important words which are john
fishing big tunas and sashimi
hey john i went fishing the other day
for big tunas to eat delicious sashimi
did you see what i just did there i used
the toner voice the pauses and the
emphasizing of words to make it sound
more interesting
descriptive and interesting word
you can always say things more
interesting by just using descriptive
and interesting words
for example let's take the same sentence
hey john i went fishing the other day
for big tunas to eat delicious sashimi
some people just sound boring because
they choose boring words so with this
sentence they say it like this john i
went fishing for tuna the other day
yeah
and
why would people want to hear that
what's so interesting about that
make it more interesting wow john you
have to hear this yesterday i went
fishing 50 kilometers from shore and
then suddenly something huge took the
line it went off like a ferrari it just
took line and i battled it for 30
minutes and then when i landed it it was
a big yellowfin tuna perfect for sashimi
and that is exactly what i did i made
fresh sashimi now that gave john the
whole picture he could see
the whole story so
make things interesting never lie but
just explain the full context to them
with interesting words
don't use crotch word
do you know what i'm talking about a lot
of people use crutch words because
it's just out of habit or because they
they want to use this crutch word so
that their brain can catch up to what
they want to say these are words like uh
so
like
i was like
you know
or even swear words you start the
conversation i say hey yesterday i went
um
so
you know
[Music]
well
so yesterday you know
if you take that along to speak people
lose interest they just want you to get
to the point
so don't use crutch words
eye contact
eye contact is super important well it
also depends on where you live your
culture right but people usually connect
with you
by looking at your eyes
so let them look at your eyes and look
at them don't look down don't look away
while you talk to them because there's
no personal connection here right when i
look away but now when i look at you
you see now we're connecting
you know people who talk too much do
that often and then they don't see the
other person's non-verbal communication
that they are actually getting annoyed
because they are talking too much
no don't have a staring contest just
make eye contact around 40 to 50 you can
look away and then look at the person
talk a little bit you know look away
talk to the person but if you look at
the person the whole time you know it's
getting getting a little bit weird
your eyes have the power to show people
how serious
sincere and truthful you really are
oh before i forget if you like this
video so far chances are you'll like the
rest of my channel as well so if you're
new here remember to subscribe i would
really love the support now let's move
on to the next one
number three nonverbal communication
what do you normally do with your body
when you're communicating when you're
talking to people what do you do over
your hands your arms neck feet
legs and shoulders
if you want to be more charismatic your
body needs to enhance what you're saying
there are basically well yeah two major
categories
open body language or closed body
language when you talk arms crossed it
usually gives people the impression that
you are not fully open to them you are
more closed an eyebrow race usually
means you are calling attention to your
face or message
teachers do this a lot
mirror body language
if you mirror the body language of
someone that you're talking to it
usually means that you want to connect
with them the same goes for them if they
mirror your body language while you are
talking
laughing at the same time also adds to
this but just make sure you're not
overdoing it that it's not too
noticeable
smile
you know what it means but there are
actually three different well major
types of smiles that people can give you
studies show a reward smile which is
given as a praise for example to a joke
an affiliate smile is given to show a
bond between people and then a dominance
smile people give that to signify higher
social status never do the dominance
smile you know it's
nobody likes arrogant people so don't be
arrogant don't do that there are
actually a lot more different types of
smile but i like the
the grin smile you know because that has
got to go together with your eyes
so yeah smile more be positive because
people like friendly positive people
people who are smiling
the head tilt
you can do it this way when you talk to
someone or this way
this
it became a habit for me since i did a
lot of modeling
and um man it just became a habit with
all the posing i only later found out
what it really means
it means that you're more open to
someone else when you show this
vulnerable area in your neck well that's
what the scientists say i don't really
believe it i just know it's more
interesting to tilt your head different
ways when you're talking to someone you
know so it's not just like this static
and boring the whole time
hand gestures i just did it you know
hand gestures
i used to do this a lot back when i
started the the videos man it was a
little bit too much my hands were just
flying all over the place while talking
about certain things every word that i
say is like this
so i didn't notice it until someone
mentioned it in the comment section and
then when i looked there was a few more
people who mentioned it and then i
thought okay man is this true so i went
back i watched some of the videos and i
realized yeah it is true my hands were
flying all over the place so i stopped
so use hand gestures but use it the
right way
for example open palms usually mean that
you are open
sincere and honest
good posture
it's extremely important when it comes
to being charismatic because confidence
and being charismatic the two of those
they go together
so if you are slouchy when your back is
bent and your shoulders kind of drop it
doesn't look that good
usually most men as well their stomach
kind of comes out you know you see this
little
yeah yeah now you can see your stomach
looks fat as well you know so you look
sloppy look lazy to a lot of people you
know good posture is so much better
stand up straight walk straight sit
straight carry yourself with dignity and
self respect and then you will have
better charisma as well
stop touching and scratching
you know when you talk to people and
they kind of do this and they even look
and they do the oh it's disgusting don't
scratch and pick at pimples or small
bumps on your head or arms or body or
anywhere when you're talking some people
even pick at their nose or ears don't do
that
not only does it distract people from
what you're actually saying but it's
also disgusting and it takes your
charisma away like that so don't do it
facial expressions
people will read your facial expressions
and when you don't look interested
people will think you are not interested
if you look bored people will think you
are bored you get what i'm saying
when you're busy speaking just one
sentence
your face speaks a thousand words
so your facial expressions need to go
together and enhance what you're saying
if it doesn't do that then people won't
trust you because the two
doesn't connect it doesn't make sense
look at this
i'm very happy
i'm so sad today i'm very sad it doesn't
make sense right your frowns eyes
eyebrows your lips and even your nose
tells people what you are really
thinking and feeling
listen
you are not a robot
so bring in your expressions when you
talk to people
a small grin before you are about to say
something funny
a frown when you are shaking your head
to show you're a disagreement about
something
raise your eyebrows when you are excited
about something you see you need to draw
people in to feel what you're saying and
not just hear what you're talking about
to some people this comes very naturally
but for others well they need to
learn this to do it effectively let me
give you a few examples with one
sentence
daniel you're not going to believe this
japan uses sunflowers to clear up
radiation
daniel you're not going to believe this
man japan
uses sunflowers to clear up radiation
wow that's pretty cool
daniel you're not going to believe this
japan uses sunflowers to clear up
radiation how cool is that wow that's
pretty cool
know your audience
this is very important you need to
change the way you talk to different
people because if you know who you are
talking to and you change the way you
talk to them it will be easier for you
to talk in a way that they will
understand you better for example you
won't talk the same way to a 10 year old
than you would with someone who is over
50 years old to be more charismatic you
should not just focus on yourself but
you should focus on the people you are
talking to and there are many things
that you need to take into consideration
age sex culture hobbies world view
desires goals
education
language and so much more people are
different you know so you might be
charismatic to one person but not
to another and that is why it's
important to improve your emotional
intelligence because if you can do that
then you can also improve your charisma
if you want to know how to improve your
emotional intelligence then watch this
video here and i'll see you there before
you go always remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys